hallo das ist wieder einmal waren
willkommen zu einem neuen video heute
gibt es einen plan wie habt ihr schon
richtig gelesen wir testen
selbstgemachte polnische gerichte nato
kommt später hierher und will mit mir
wieder polnisches essen testen was er
nicht weiß ist dass ich es selber mache
und dass keines dieser produkte fleisch
enthalten wird also kein fleisch von
tieren aber und deswegen steht hier auch
werbevideo wir haben fleisch von
pflanzen dieses video entsteht nämlich
in kooperation mit ceo terry butcher und
zwar haben sie mich gebeten einen freund
zu bringen indem ich ihm etwas kochen
bei dem er glaubt dass das fleisch drin
ist aber eigentlich pflanzliches
fleischers denn gemeldet harry potter
hat es sich zur aufgabe gemacht richtig
gute produkte zu produzieren ohne dabei
fleisch zu verwenden von fleisch
liebhabern für fleischliebhaber und ich
finde dieses experiment gerade besonders
spannend denn die polnische küche ist
sehr fleisch lasten und da kann das
holländische unternehmen mit der terry
butcher mir bestimmt gut helfen ich bin
echt ziemlich aufgeregt muss ich sagen
ich hoffe dass ich es gut hinbekomme und
jetzt zeige ich euch was ich kochen
möchte das mach zwei rezepte gefunden
absolute klassiker wie rocky mit
hackfleisch und pilzen und barsch das
ist eine rote bete suppe sehr komisch
und beim dritten polnischen klassiker
konnte ich sogar auch mein kochbuch zu
greifen
denn was ist polnischer als für dieses
crazy experiment habe ich auch wirklich
alles genommen was ich in meinem rede
kühlregal noch gefunden habe
und zwar lässt die sau raus würstchen
beflügeln die betitelung gallone
hick-hack belchen und mein absoluter
favorit vom namen her sieht schick aus
bürger versteht ihr würdigen chicken
chips dann würde ich sagen fangen wir an
zu kochen denn otto kommt ja später und
möchte etwas testen als im besten fall
sehr gut schmeckt wir schaffen das wir
schaffen das wir schaffen das ich denke
am besten wäre es wenn wir es mit
unserem bigos anfangen denn der muss so
schön ein suppen und für biebers
brauchen wir 500 gramm sauerkraut 500
gramm weißkohl und wacholderbeeren drei
lorbeerblätter eine gemüsezwiebel zwei
esslöffel tomatenmark und salz und
pfeffer h und was natürlich nicht fehlen
natürlich unsere vegetarisches fleisch
und eine vanessa die alles kocht schritt
novarro einst war sie unseren weißkohl
schnibbeln und mit der kraft der video
schneidtechnik wird dieser code jetzt
klein geschnitten
und so schnell geht es heute immer mehr
wir brauchen jetzt unsere steuerkraft
com wird in deutschland über sauerkraut
zugeschrieben polen ist jeder sauerkraut
dort macht man sich auch auf meinem
bruder hausmannskost markt hoffe ich
dass es passt alles in den top3
lorbeerblätter kommen jetzt dazu und
fünf über häuser wären jetzt beginnt
unser fleisch experiment so richtig denn
wir schneiden unsere lass die sau raus
würstchen die 10 sogar richtig nach
bratwurst aus und unsere würstchen
kommissar hinter und das arbeitsdienst
ruhig das ganze jetzt mal in einen
größeren topf reingemacht
ich habe mich schon die ganze zeit
gefragt wann kann ich endlich mal wieder
zwiebeln schneider david hawkins gelöst
[Musik]
ich werde auch ein paar hackbällchen und
beflügeln da geht's rein machen damit
man am ende einfach so verschiedene
gebratene fleischsorten sieht so die
schneide ich auch noch klein für sie
diese fleisch passiv und sie beraten wir
hoffen dass unser faire mittel
[Musik]
gute idee die moral von luk kauf nehmen
das sieht aus als ob das vielleicht drin
wären sie aus wie die wirkliche liebe
also leute könnt ihr sagen was ihr wollt
aber das gebiet aus
ich bin so stolz ich bin raus stets
aufrecht als nächstes machen wir unseren
weg weiter und führen sonst brauchen wir
sind grün lorbeerblätter salz rote beete
april essig zucker und knoblauch und
vanessa wir beginnen unsere suppengrün
wir vergessen
dazu kommen noch zwei lorbeerblätter und
sechskerner piment die tecdax und da wir
keinen speck verwenden habe ich
geräuchertes meersalz gefunden und
geräuchertes meersalz gibt hoffentlich
diesen reucher geschmack ab den sonst so
speck geben würde
einmal den riecht es
und darauf hießen wir jetzt ein liter
wasser
deckel drauf unser gemüse muss jetzt
eine stunde lang kochen und in der zeit
kümmern wir uns schon um die rote beete
akku ist gerade zu hause wartet darauf
dass er zu mir kommen kann und ihr
polnisches essen essen aber er hat keine
ahnung dass ich hier stundenlang für ihn
in der küche stehe aber warme ware war
moore bauhof auch schon wieder
ich hab dir fasst jens cockpits besetzt
es sich eigentlich auch sein dass ich
rot weiß an hart leute polen
das ist alles die sind es ist noch suppe
und das ist so viel arbeit am ende wird
die brühe gegeben
hier ist jetzt unsere pure grünes hemd
und dann schaffen wir jetzt noch unsere
rote beete ab alexa stopp und jetzt
machen wir unsere suppengemüse brüder
rhein ist jetzt halten extrem klare
brühe oder lecker so last but sicher
nicht liest chirurgie mit hackfleisch
und pilzen wir brauchen mehr wasser ohne
hier kapellchen stammpiloten
zehn bands und pfeffer petersilie und
wieder eine vanessa die alles zubereitet
okay leute das ist unser letzter schritt
ich habe gerade abfragen gerufen er
kommt in einer stunde das heißt wir
haben eine stunde zeit und promis zu
machen alles aufzuräumen und so spuren
zu verwischen und dann zu testen ich bin
gespannt wurde man müsste meinen dass
lockenkopf videos endlich mal so richtig
cool schneiden kann sowieso angeber so
ja ich komme gar nicht hin
guckt immer beim schneiden können
so auch meine hier kapellchen schneide
ich jetzt auch so klein wie möglich das
geht eigentlich ganz gut aus so ein
experiment starten und zwar lass die sau
raus würstchen muss ich auch sehr gut
kleinschulen ein bisschen öl in die
pfanne und da kommt erst mal unsere
zwiebeln
jetzt folgt unser phlow demmin jot und
natürlich nehme ich für ein polnisches
gericht polnische gemüsebrühe wow
[Musik]
ich will endlich fertig sein
wir haben jetzt natürlich unter pierogi
füllung aber wir brauchen die die
zutaten für den teig werden jetzt
geknetet ja ich glaub ich ein guter teil
wo gerade party ist einfach noch nie
land situation gerade hier meine gäste
kommen ich bin nicht harry in der küche
mit einem glas stechen die heizkreise
aus ich bin ihr uns ein biologie und
einer verfüllung und fühlen und dann
habt ihr hier muss jetzt arthur in mein
schlafzimmer verweisen damit ich hier in
ruhe fertig machen kann so leute ich
muss jetzt die kamera umstellen ich
koche die police noch fertig und dann
sehen uns gleich beim test ist sie
warten bis sie die wand
warum bin ich jetzt blind doch ist es
lustig ok ich hab' das den tages mit
polnischen sachen testen ja und was
hätten wir wohl selbst gemacht den
bäumen
jetzt den ganzen tag gekocht das hast du
richtig selber gemacht habe ich richtig
selber sind die ja zusammen
die hab ich gerade noch das glaube ich
nicht da ist noch die fans die caddies
erkennst du was ich gekocht habe because
i was not bisschen bisschen ohne
bisschen wenig fahrt bisschen fahrt und
das hast du töne mehr
ihr habt es gesehen die wie hast du hast
sie waren wie schon von gestern oder
hast du heute um den lecker als große
finale
was musst du wissen willst du hast
konnte preetz in der mühlacker und
ordnete hitze muss man steinpilze der
mega des mega man schon den kasseler
vermuten
welchem gericht kein fleisch war ich
glaube ich glaube es ist klar so leute
sind ist kein stück
nein das ist nicht gut
wie der tu ist noch kommt und du nicht
nur polnisches essen gekocht nein was
richtig und es gibt noch mehr produkte
geschnetzeltes schicken
wie geil es schmeckt alles gut ja das
ist wirklich also jährlich gerne noch
pilze gesehen aber sonst ist alles mega
gibt diese nordpolen ja ja auf jeden
fall zum beispiel habe niemals niemals
speckwürfel obmann kilo gegessen aber
viele leute kenntnissen das brauchen wir
nicht nein wir brauchen kein fleisch
wenn wir das war toll oder
vielleicht habt ihr das wieder gefallen
wenn ihr alter nicht kennen dann
verlinke ich ihnen auch nach unten hin
david alaba zu mir nach hause und ihren
tanzen zu hause letzte posten ab
[Musik]
[Applaus]